>> PEWDIEPIE CLAPS WHILE WALKING INTO THE FRAME
We did it, we beat T-series to *Felix's inner demon takes over* 69 million subscribers.
I've never been more proud.
I never actually felt a shit of respect for you guys but god damn it you pulled through.
But I just realized, I made a huge mistake
Getting 69M subscribers, isn't the most important number that exists
That's right
I'm talking about 69696969 subscribers
And
A collab with Takeshi69
So boom.
I'm with two people
*Tekashi69 repeats his booms several times in order to assert the ultimate dominance upon everyone else in the room*
*boom*
I'm leading the show
You know what 'persona' means?
Yeh
What does 'persona' mean?
*Tekashi 69 confused as fuck for a minute* UAHHHHH
What does that mean?
Awkward silence.
Like uh.. like an act.
That's when we know we have done it
That's when I can throw in the towel and be like
>> PEWDIEPIE EMITS A LOUD SPITTING SOUND
Take the spot T-series.
I DON'T CARE! (I care immensely)
6969696969 Million subscribers
Can we hit it?
Please.
It will be the last thing I ask you
Now let's just jump into the memes guys
>> NOTEBLOCKS RECREATE LWIAY/YIAY INTRO SONG.
When pewds hits 69 million and brings back bonus meme all in the same- day
You guys are the man.
or waman.
Or whatever you are, no discrimination.
Cya, Marzia. :')
When all 7.5 million subscribers are sad.
So she got as many views as subscribers,
Oh, and it looks like she's crying too!
Ayyy, uber eats.
I'm doing my part, from Bangladesh
Covered up 3 kilometers
>> PEWDIEPIE BREAKS OFF AND LAUGHS
Jesus Christ.
Thank you, we have people working from the inside!
This is perfect!
I've never been more proud indian bros.
Now a lot of people have been saying
it's like a "India Versus T-Series"
No!
That has never been the case. (Maybe a little bit)
This is what we need to do, we need more people working from the inside
It's funny actually, a friend on mine sent me, from London
This is not from reddit, this is a friend that sent it to me
I appreciate the Comic Sans, great choice
This is how we will win.
Its not over YET
We need an investigation, T-Series.
Pewdiepie viewers: watch this
Kowaiski, analysis.
I should just review and get done with it.
Although, bros...
A N A L Y S I S
The perfectly balanced meme does not ex-
Wow, I don't know what to say. I don't know what to say.
Perfect sequels don't exist
0 subscriber specal!
1 subs yas!
Dane thanks his 1st subscriber... His Grandma. :)
>> Chuckle
But where is the one subscriber specal??
'At least he don't use bots.'
Goddamn right. Maybe thats what we need to do.
We need to broaden the nine year old demographic.
Everyone go ask your grandma to subscribe... (rip headphone users) RIGHT NOW
If you haven't asked your grandma yet.. i'M wAiTiNg... This video will NOT continue.
'Hopefully nobody made this joke yet.'
Yeah well *eh*someone already make the joke, well practically.
But its a good- its a good one
My sister drew Pewds in colored pencil, I want him to see it! <3
*kisses fingers like an italian chef* beautiful
this is
incredible art but where are all the
texts? Where are all the info saying
"subscribe to PewDiePie"? What is this?
Some kind of joke? Don't waste my time...
Bought
a small ad space god-*breaks into a chuckle*
See this is what I'm talking about.
You bought a bottom local newspaper and published it
Help pewds be the first
one to reach 69- this is how we reached our goal.
We worked together goddamnit.
I'm proud. I'm actually proud.
Made some "Bitch Lasagne". That actually looks good.
That honestly looks like a delicious Bitch Lasagna.
(pls do the rest) When we hit 69 69 69 69 69
million subscribers I'll personally
deliver this lasagna activity series
smart guys saying that girls can't be
gamers saying girls can't be video games
so they won't be able to quote him on it
I mean yeah it's like you have to make
it so blatantly obvious if you make a
joke these days you can't just say how
girls aren't gamers doesn't matter if it
was a joke
so yeah you got it congratulations you
figured me out what are you gonna do huh
turn me into the media doesn't matter
I'm not scared please don't please don't
turn me into the me please
when you see baby please honey I got
removed from Spotify yet someone else
keeps reuploading it it's not my fault
just let you know it's not my fault
waves don't care about your sandcastle
and clearly not mr. ben shapiro either
if we be t-series i will bring back
bonus me that's right
oh well it did came back yes right what
can I say I'm a humble leader I'm a
humble King if you guys deliver so do I
remember 6-9 6-9 6-9 seconds nine we
take a she said no not November you not
you lose you're not sweetie so you don't
understand you dumb ball of balls you
dumb you're just dumb one down two to go
okay this meme review was epic if we can
get dr. Phil or LMS or Takeshi 69 or
nearly anyone that would be epic it's
this tracer yep
and no one currently has tracer
so anyone could choose tracer makes
sense to me so then I'll be trade sir
I'm already tracer this is why women
aren't in video games the devil exists
God Satan okay
I'm seen picture I gotta find this video
it's like a t series mr. beast edition
how much are they paying you Simon huh
how much are they paying you to do this
Simon join us whatever a tea service is
paying you I'll double this
please Simon we need more people working
on the inside next name I am black and
hereby give you know this is not gonna
be good Peter Pan and pass renewal which
lets him justify any time he said the N
word in the past this now makes what he
said at the rich book I expect to see
season 2 of scare PewDiePie soon nice
tried T series nice try but I'm not
falling for it saw a potential me format
on the his Twitter felix having a white
screen behind him could be a new meme
format exclusive to the subreddit yeah
you're right I didn't think about that
when I posted it oh no what have I done
upgrade perfect oh my god never wanting
to do that again Conan O'Brien PD PI
okay there's this a good me I'm willing
to give it one more shot
just one more shot for you have sinned
for not being a subscriber to my child
PewDiePie for he needs our help to
banish T series from YouTube for once
and for all it seems to be that's T
series made a deal with Satan to become
number one so smash that subscribe
button hit the bell for notifications
and sprint the good news for PewDiePie
will remain as number one
if we succeed I will forgive all your
sins oh wow
I'd like to bless valincia and Anisha
tow for sending their regards Jesus
joins the team now there's no way we can
lose people's paths being subjugated by
a league of legends world stream oh
that's awesome this is the power of
everyone working together and doing one
part they're part it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if you're losers I never
leave your computer and doesn't haven't
done anything with your life you now
finally have a chance to do something
meaningful god damn it
found a computer I'd work with so much
Google account logged on so I did that
person a favor
and smashed sir scribe you didn't hit
the bell button what are you thinking am
I supposed to be thankful now do it
right and do it again oh wait what is
this Romania Wow hey I didn't know they
had tape in Romania mad let's everyone
what an absolute medal it a very proud
thank you I think I think we and dr.
Phil needs to feel each other if you
know what I mean
do you watch PewDiePie no I don't I
won't judge but can you sub to him so he
can stay number one you are the second
guy who has said this to me Oh Lord
well then subscribe already it's not
that hard it's really not that hard
it looks like marker play Oh mark apply
another kid these days oh my god that's
weird
why mark you can't just go around
stealing books
I wish I saw that that is amazing that's
how you know she's white we made history
69 million you goddamn right we did but
it's not over yet
we're so close god damn it so close I
can taste it now go out there tell your
grandma and do your part thank you for
watching this video thank you for all
the memes and thank you for all the
amazing support but most of all thank
you for 69 million subscribers you did
your job
so here okay alright move on get the ass
outro please